if I divide up my soul of evolution
slice it up like salami you get these
guys these cylinders
this is Nepali methicillin ah and you
add up a whole bunch of them no big deal
okay but if I could rotate around this
axis then it stands to reason that I can
rotate around a deoxys I like and I will
still get a shape which I could divide
up into these Salafi cylinders right so
you have a look at this for me for a
second the first thing I want to point
out is you can see parts of this curve
like they wiggle around and they'll be
really if we pretended around any
answers you can still do them but I
don't care what's happening down here if
the interval that I'm integrating over
is up here right so this can do whatever
this is the particular these are the
batteries that are going to create a
bomb okay now just like before I'm going
to pull out one of these slices okay so
here's what it looks like and just like
before I need to know radius and I need
to know height in order to work out the
volume of this individual cylinder okay
but because you can see I draw this
completely differently right all the
bits are different right for starters
the height thankfully is an actual
height this time it's actually vertical
but see is its vertical it's no longer
going to be DX it will be dy right and
conversely because the radius here is
now on the horizontal axis right these
are my radii will be here then they're
not going to be Y values they are going
to be X values so when you work out the
volume of this individual cylinder it's
going to be pi times the radius which is
x squared times the height okay and then
you form your integral just like you did
before total volume equals our Y we go
from now you can see I've made my
boundaries C and D so from C
the of pi X where do you live now it
doesn't take that much imagination to
see that it is horribly easy to confuse
this formula for you with this formula
per volume which one is which okay now
the way that I remember it the way that
helps me is to say okay which is the
operating part here which is the thing
is doing the action
okay and in the same way that if I gave
you a function right and then I said
differentiate this with respect to X
right that DX is what to tell you what's
going on right that's the guy that's
kind of like that's like the pilot
that's setting the direction for this
day okay in the same way over here with
our original volume you are rotating and
which axis you rotating around the
x-axis right so that's why this is with
respect to X you're rotating around that
axis here you're retaining around the
vertical axis so this is it the reading
with respect to Y so think about this
time this is the guy doing the operating
right here is the volume when rotating
around the x-axis it is the volume when
rotating around the y-axis now just go
back right notice I've got x squared dy
so I need I had Y is a function of X
here right so you just sub in for
instance the example we just did
we went 0 to 2pi what did we say x
squared squared DX right remember that
over here I mean I know that's not the
particulars that I drew here but if I
were taking that same curve x squared
right and I wanted to consider the
volume when I rotate around the y axis
okay I would say okay well my batteries
are not going to be 0 to 2 anymore is x
squared right so be 0 to 4 I think
that's 2 squared then when I put in x
squared well hold on a second the graph
that I'm interested in right now is y
equals x squared so instead of x squared
I just write Y and then I integrate with
respect to Y
like now this is a like this picture and
this picture have nothing to do with
this function that we were actually
working with before these are just
examples that I've just shown so you can
visually okay so for example if this was
on if this this is going to be something
actually very nice to you okay
because you would typically expect to
get a function like this as what I
equals 2x cubed minus 2 I for a proven
I'm very bad at doing this but anyway
I'm gonna try anyway nothing like that I
need to get Y this is y is a function of
X right I would need to get X as a
function of Y which is pretty much a
disaster you will never get a question
like that what you might get was
something like this suppose and this is
not the graph anymore okay let's suppose
you've got this that's doable right what
I need now is x squared
how do I get x squared out of that okay
first I'm gonna have to take the cube
root so I'm gonna get a cube root of y
equals x minus 1 I need to get the X by
itself so I say X equals the cube root
of y plus 1 right and there's lastly I
want x squared not X so I'm gonna take
that whole thing and I'm going to square
now that that also looks bad doesn't it
but it's ok it's ok
the cube root of Y is y the power of 1/3
right so this looks to me like it'll be
wider power two-thirds plus 2y power of
1/3 plus 1 and that's actually quite
easy to integrate right you do all the
powers plus 1 bring the power out the
front sorry divided by the car NUI fine
okay so we'll have a look a bit more of
those tomorrow and also what happens
when you get holo parts inside of your
solid ok so thanks everyone